politifact has archived a fact check
they have
rebunked the lab leak hypothesis
archived fact checked tucker carlson
guest heirs debunked conspiracy theory
that coveted 19 was created in a lab
interesting they have an editor's note
from may 17 2021
the great rebunking they say when this
fact check was first published in
september 2020
politifact sources included researchers
who asserted the soros co
uh covet 2 virus could not have been
manipulated
that assertion is now more widely
disputed for that reason
we are removing this fact check from our
database pending a more
thorough review currently we consider
the claim to be unsupported by evidence
and in dispute
the original fact check in its entirety
is preserved below for transparency and
archival purposes
read our may 2021 report for more
information blah blah blah blah blah
what they're basically saying is they
published fake news based on some guy's
opinion
let me stress they say researchers who
asserted
politifact can we change your name to
pull it opinion
because having some guys come on and say
here's what i think
is not fact checking it's opinion
checking
i could pull the opinion out of the ass
of some homeless guy in my alley who
says that he thinks it's not true and i
can publish to my website how about i do
that
i don't know who these researchers are
this is what annoys me about the
mainstream media
our opinion guys are facts your opinion
guys
are wrong that's the name of the game
yeah i mean if you don't have total
content for the new york times the
washington post yet i don't
know what it would take one of the weird
things about facts is they can be wrong
like a fact can be not right but it's
still
like if you say the sky is red that is a
fact
that is a factual statement it's not
correct you're
also wrong but it is still it's not an
opinion it's a statement of fact that is
not right that's that's actually that
it's actually a good point
and i think you understand this you have
to make a statement to fact
in order to be sued for defamation it's
a false statement of fact
right but it has to be legally
considered a statement to fact there's a
factual statement in this context though
right like so this is clearly
susceptible to fact-checking right like
did the did the virus come from a lab or
not
the real i think the real question is
would it be a conspiracy theory and i
would argue that it couldn't be a
conspiracy theory because there's no
conspiracy
theorized right well not just that it's
when this story came out it was a is it
possible it no one said
it is well a lot of people said it was
but like in in media in conservative
media in independent media
they were saying interesting interesting
and the reason for it like right when
this story broke i even talked about it
before there was anything happening in
the u.s
because the wuhan institute was right
next to the wet market right
and so everybody was like yo and you
don't you don't have to say you don't
have to think there's like some
colluding
chinese scientists deciding to you know
evil
and unleash this virus on everybody you
could be like somebody made a mistake
that's not a conspiracy theory right you
know if one person
could have done something it's not a
conspiracy right i always said that it's
about that i think i told you this joke
or
before like people would say the notre
dame the idea that notre dame burned
because of arson oh that's a conspiracy
theory
no one person can burn down a building
or not a conspiracy or it could have
been a dude smoking or flicked a
cigarette
right exactly could have been an
accident could have been intentional
whatever
right so this is the problem with
today's media is that if it doesn't fit
the narrative
and they want power they will
immediately assert opinion as fact and
get away with it
it's also they they almost they see
their jobs totally wrong like this whole
you know since it's literally just since
trump since trump they've seen their
jobs no longer as like
discovering truth but rather policing
heresy
right so here's a here's a weird fact
did you know that like at the turn of
the century
they're imagine okay here's the here's
the question really frame it
what do you think the most popular major
was at the turn of the 20th century the
most popular what
major in college what do you think
people graduated folklore and mythology
close enough theology wow
there's always going to be a market for
mediocre intellects who can do nothing
but point and say something doesn't fit
conventional wisdom
right so we have to do something with
those people and in the turn of the
century
the you know the con received wisdom
meant that they would all be theology
majors policing heresy
now they're all journalists policing
conspiracy theories
everything's a conspiracy even when one
person does it because conspiracy theory
just means
story we don't agree with correct but
but i i have to stress politifact
did no research on this none whatsoever
they get an opinion
and someone guy goes in my opinion i
think it's not true debunked
we have officially debunked a conspiracy
theory by getting a guy with an opinion
to say it wasn't true
well well there are scientists who have
tons of opinions on like string theory
or m theory or whatever
and they probably don't agree with each
other on the math which one's the
conspiracy whichever one the
corporations dictate
so here i got a bunch of sources for you
check it out
you may have heard that rand paul
questioned fauci about gain of function
research
newsweek reported on this we've talked
about it with luke when he was here
gain of function research i think luke
took a more um
apocalyptic view of it where it was like
to make you know luke was saying to make
the virus as crazy as possible
gain of function involves yes increasing
virality or something but not always to
make it the most right you know it
doesn't mean you're going from zero to
100
maybe you're right from 10 to 15 you
know or 10 to 11. like yeah what if it
was
like if this if this evolves in this way
how do we deal with it in this way
and so yes there was funding that went
to gain a function research
fauci lied in this testimony even the
even politifact says well there was
funding from the u.s to wuhan's lab for
gain of function
research and uh now the story is like
maybe the lab
lab league thing is potent is possible
let me pull up some of these things i
pulled up so
we got this this from april 28 2020 nih
cancels funding for bat coronavirus
research project
the abrupt termination comes at the
research drew president trump's
attention
for its ties to the wuhan institute of
virology
nih was providing funding for bat
coronavirus research at wuhan's
institute of virality that's where the
bat coronavirus came from this is
well we
right exactly like across the street so
this is
the scientist.com a newsguard certified
source 100 over 100 and i use this
because
if it's wrong don't get mad at me
newsguard said it is the cream of the
crop the best of the best and they
reported this a year before
we have this story from february 25th
2019 human error in high biocontainment
labs a likely pandemic
threat incidents causing potential
exposure to pathogens frequently in
highest career labs
you get the point they talk about a
bunch of stories it's not necessarily
about wuhan the point is
the the likelihood of a lab leak
potentially high
they say human error in high is a likely
pandemic threat
so is it possible that a pathogen leaked
from a lab according to the bulletin.org
i don't know if it's like the bastion of
this one's not newsguard certified
they said they were they reported in
2019 it was when we go over to the
washington post
fact-checking the paul fauci flap over
wuhan lab funding
this is where it gets funny because they
start playing games well it's not
really gain of reap function it's it's
overly verbose
the grant was it was it was more like
dark money it wasn't specifically
for you know uh uh bat corona virus
sounds like [ __ ]
yeah you know when you said he lied i
would be like
he was misleading no he literally i
don't know i mean because like
like from my understanding is that he
defines gain of function research in a
very narrow and lawyerly way
that that's that i'm sorry that's lying
okay how does he do you know how he
defines it we
have never i'm mis with all due respect
you're wrong
we have never provided funding for gain
of function research and then you have
politifact
yes they did gain a function research
but fauci is arguing semantics
you know nah you know pharma got a lot
of [ __ ]
from everybody for a really long time uh
and you know our public health
authorities were always held in
extremely high esteem like if you
actually looked at that right like
what are people's opinion of the nih cdc
versus what other people's opinion
pharma companies
nih looks like it probably caused the
pandemic and killed a few million people
like or has a has a role i think i think
the lab leak hypothesis is right
um and if not nih then institutional
public health
right right uh and farmer companies
solved it
[Laughter]
right did you see the video from the
white house where they're all hugging
and kissing
and like no one's wearing any masks no
yeah yeah that's new
and so i tweeted the pandemic was over
somewhat facetiously
youtube chill i'm making it point that
the white house
nobody was doing anything and
i mean so there we go i mean the the
taxes in florida have lifted
restrictions obviously a while ago
and now i was recently watching there's
a cnn segment
with fauci and uh chris cuomo and cuomo
was like why aren't there
uh vaccine passports and fauci said
because we can't force people to get the
vaccine
so that means if the guideline is if
you're vaccinated you're okay take your
mask off and these businesses can choose
what they want to do
what else is left people who don't want
to get it aren't going to get it but i
will mention one thing that's really
hilarious
how does it make sense that if you get
the vaccine
you can still get sick but you'll be
asymptomatic like bill maher was
recently
so you'll be able to give people covet
right
if you're that's not my understanding of
the latest sciences that suggests that
it does
it's very not transmissible by people
who've been vaccinated
in the same way make sense of it before
then
then i stand then i will stop right
there and say all right make sense there
you go
so then uh why should people who aren't
vaccinated wear masks
um who aren't vaccinated other people
who aren't vaccinated don't get sick
well i mean like at this point that yeah
i think you're right that there's
that's kind of a weird argument to be
making in general i think once
you know once facts you know math
squaring before was a public health
measure because there's no other measure
available at all to like deal with
spread but like
once everybody has the personal choice
about whether to be vaccinated or not
uh the value of masks you know what you
know what's really uh
irksome what the lab leak hypothesis was
published
last year by the washington post and
that was like really the first time i
saw it
there was also stories from the daily
mail and a few others that were asking
these questions
and immediately very left-leaning
democrat media said it's a conspiracy
theory
political politifact for instance
everyone who did that
should be out of a job in a in a
properly functioning media environment
every one of those journalists that
would be like because like think about
are there more important how many more
important questions are there than
how did the pandemic that killed three
million people start
right and you went out there and you
said the theory that actually looks like
the most prominent
was impossible and it debunked
conspiracy theory based on quit
go be a barista do something else and it
like got people's livelihoods destroyed
and like people that would talk about it
online would get shut down
right like lost revenue and things i
agree with you yeah
go be a barista you're not a journalist
anymore like you you're journalists
maybe we need like professional
licensing for journalists in the same
way that we have i wonder now for
uh lawyers i'll say this anybody out
there who knows anybody who had a strike
or was taken off who was taken down or
suspended for talking about lab leak
should file a a lawsuit against
politifact yeah
there's there's real damages yeah that's
a real yeah actual damages for
defamation right
you know although i mean since it
probably you know
they would say specifically
intentionally lying but
yeah reckless disregard for the truth by
claiming that an opinion of a researcher
was a fact
yeah people have tried you've looked
it's hard james o'keefe won that new
york times
motion to dismiss he won the motion to
dismiss right which is where the judge
said
i if you're going to insert opinions you
have to say it's an opinion that makes
sense to me
we'll see where it goes from there but
at least he got to that point yeah
so you can't just i think it's defeat us
to be like well they'll probably say no
well i'll file it anyway
you have to be you have to be able to
allege malice right like and reckless
reckless disregard but reckless
disregard has attack i mean it has a
technical meaning like
you know and that's like it's ultimately
gonna be like conscious disregard
right so like and proving that's always
going to be very challenging i mean
you got to fight and the o'keefe case
has the unique thing of like they have
the
timestamp of when the emails were sent
and the
impossibility of comment which is how he
got over um
asserting the problem of asserting mails
so all these news outlets
started lying youtube just agreed with
the liars and then negatively impacted
people
and now they're all starting to come
around why is it that conservatives
just buckle so easily well you know we
just don't control the media
and it'd be really nice if we did yeah
the media became more and more
left-leaning and maybe it'll change
you know daily wires doing particularly
well we need to overturn new york times
v sullivan
um it's it's too hard to prove
defamation like the the intense standard
that we've talked about malice is
is way because it means you have to
prove someone's state of mind when they
can't wouldn't it be more reasonable to
just be able to
allege defamation file a suit say to a
judge
here's the fact that they got wrong and
proof
and if it's true the judge can say issue
a correction right and also i mean think
about it from the perspective of like
what is definition right defamation is
you've said something that's injured
someone else's reputation
well the person whose reputation is
injured is an innocent victim had
nothing to do with it
right you just talked about them and
lied about them and said said something
false about them that hurt them that did
them damage
like maybe you should just be liable for
that maybe we shouldn't look at whether
or not you knew
you were lying like maybe you were or
maybe we just have a lower standard of
like negligence like
if you were just if you didn't take
reasonable care and you said something
about someone
that was false and did them dancing is
it so hard for the new york times to
just put
apologies we were wrong about this right
like i mean or god forbid they actually
just have to
you know they have a process where their
editors ensure
that whenever they make factual
statements about someone that could
injure their reputation
they take reasonable care yeah right
like they do they act like
reasonable journalists not that they
knowing the standards shouldn't be
did the new york times knowingly lie the
standard should be did they
take reasonable care what we do is we
put the burden
on the uh the plaintiff
so that but we get rid of the standards
so basically make it so that
you have to show the court what you
perceive to be defamation
and evidence to support that that it's
what they said was demonstrably false
only after those two criteria are met
then the person being sued has to
respond
i mean that's kind of the way it works
now right you have to you know allege
um and basically i mean like do go step
forward and actually presenting your
case of like here's proof to state that
it's an incorrect statement yeah i mean
usually that's
that's done that's the easy part of
defamation right usually when you bring
a defamation case you have that evidence
and honestly like you probably have to
do that
and then if so like if i said something
and then someone filed a suit against me
and said
he said you know x equals y but you know
actually it's x equals z then my
response is just
here's an article from the new york
times you know or whatever here's the
evidence backing that up would that be
sufficient
i mean it would be again probably
because you'd have to show that argue
did you take reasonable care right like
in what reasonable care is going to look
like is probably developed through
judges but we
we know what it looks like in the
context of journalism like did you
research the claim did you try and
verify it was true or false
did you make a good faith effort to do
so if yes then probably it's tough
it is tough you know it's still it's not
it's it's better it's a lot better than
can you prove that i knew i was lying or
ra that i consciously disregarded the
problem now is the new york times can
lie politifact can lie
and you cannot do anything about it and
it gets put into the record it gets
put into historical record and
encyclopedia and then people end up
believing
insane bs and that's not the way it was
in this country before
new york times d sullivan which
constitutionalized right before that
there was libel law in every
state it totally coexisted with the
first amendment that's not except
until like the the warren court decided
no we're going to eviscerate
state level libel law and impose new
federal rules
um and then it's not the way it is in
other countries too right like the
in europe uh especially in england like
libel law sounds a lot more like what i
talked about where
the standard is not did can you prove
they said something false but rather
like
did you take reasonable care yeah i'm
concerned like if
youtubers smack talk each other that one
will get busted
if we repeal times v solomon which i
don't actually know what is it exactly
times b sullivan so time z sullivan is
is the case that sets the standard for
intent in the defamation case
and that's distinct from what you're
talking about like when you're smack
talking that could be
like opinion hyperbole like if it's not
intentionally meant as true then it's
not
something that could be defamatory in
the first place right it has to be like
a false statement
you know put forward for its truth um i
don't know if we got that
exactly right would still be protected
opinions would still be protected the
question is like once you've
demonstrated that somebody said
something false about you
what do you have to prove about their
state of mind right
and if the standard is actual malice you
have to prove
not only that they said something false
but that they knew it was false when
they said it
or that they had what's called reckless
disregard for the truth but that
reckless does a lot of work you have to
prove like
conscious knowledge of or conscious
disregard of things they should have
done
uh potentially in the james o'keefe case
the new york times yeah exactly
they didn't even bother calling the
people to like fact check right they
just said
did james leave his lying it's like well
did you actually look into that no
i don't know he's like we don't that
might get reversed on appeal you know
like that that's just one
state court judge you know we don't we
don't know if that if that ultimately
proves it
whereas again negligence is very common
throughout tort law and that's not
intent like you can just be negligent if
you didn't take reasonable care
so if we repeal times we solve it could
you be negligent and not be held
responsible
well if we if we repeal times you
sullivan that times we solve and set a
federal
rule for what the intent standard had to
be in defamation cases repealing it
means okay now we're back to
state by state them themselves figuring
out what the rules should be in
defamation cases
and if i'm in texas using a youtube
video where whose
headquarters is in california talking
about someone in north dakota
then are all three states involved
welcome to choice of law
like that's actually a very con this is
not you know defamation's not the only
area of law there are obviously areas of
law contract law for example
where most things aren't there where
things aren't federalized
in civil litigation and so often times a
question comes up of which states law do
you choose to apply
um and so that's that's very complicated
uh
and each state has their own here's
another
really really big right each state has
their own laws about how to choose which
law applies
in their courts uh well texas and
florida's social media laws will be
interesting
yeah i mean so that actually is an
interesting example of
i mean not quite in the social
litigation in the civil litigation
context but um well maybe
uh but yeah like different states have
different laws and
uh you know people will find ways to
especially like one thing that happens i
mean in almost every business contract
if you sign or a lease
you'll notice that there's a choice of
law clause in those leases you sign for
an apartment
that says this this contract will be
governed by the law of
the district of columbia or whatever
right like that's you know because
that's a smart thing to include because
it eliminates that dispute you contract
you can contractually agree to which
state's law applies
yeah well defamation is uh
it's it's probably one of the most
pressing problems that we're facing
right now especially
uh in cultural politics and politics
the record as it stands over the past 10
years
is fake yeah agreed
everything well yeah because the paper
of record was putting out fake news so
the record is fake the new york times
has put out a ton of fake news
like they want awards for it awards
we've lived in the age
of obfuscation this this there's so many
it's a dark age
it really has become kind of there's so
much light that it is blinding us
and we can't see so might as well be in
the dark and i mean before they screwed
up but at least they tried
you know they had like the new york
times got rid of its public editor
i mean they got rid of their copy
editors they just do they even have fact
checkers anymore
i mean i i assume so but remember when
you get a phone call from a fact checker
and they're like hi my name's john i'm a
fact checker with new york times yeah i
got one from the new yorker a little
a while back new yorker doesn't yeah
they still do it maybe it's just too
expensive to do and so
whatever just let your activist
journalist say whatever i think it
was the new yorker that put out a fake
story about me where they mashed two
quotes together to make a totally out of
context quote
yeah yeah yeah so basically what
happened was a story i told was
offensive
to some people who then threatened i
guess i don't know exactly what happened
but i think they threatened a lawsuit so
the new yorker just wrote what they
wanted them to write
and so then they the new yorker accused
me of giving them erroneous statements
which is obviously false
what happened was a guy at the new
yorker took two different stories
and combined two quotes into one with
like a space so it sounded like
once two separate sentences from 50
minutes apart was one sentence
totally changing the context of what i
had said right and then obviously when
the other individuals involved in the
story
saw that it was lying and making them
look bad which i never said
they told them that's not true i never
said that so then instead of taking
responsibility they said tim poole
provided
erroneous statements so then i called
and said no i didn't
and the journalist told me to go screw
myself he wouldn't correct it
and it was funny because the the issue
was the person that i was the
the the story i was telling involved a
massive
corporation who scared the new yorker
they weren't scared of just one guy
so they you know ultimately just told me
to screw off wow yeah evil
evil people evil not evil
i have so little time for modern
journalism it's so it's so terrible it's
just it's it's maybe the most endlessly
frustrating
it's like because every day you see a
news article and every day you're like
oh
another you know at best misleading
article from yeah it's a big part of why
i
am concerned with cancel culture and
canceling because in an age of
propaganda you need
to have access to be able to speak who
you are and and so people can see it
from the
same people policing everybody for
misinformation and heresy
are the same people i mean i i had a
talk of the journalists the other day
and they were like you know talking
about how
no misinformation is a real threat and
i'm like you realize that
your outlets uh put forward a theory
that a billionaire real estate magnate
turned president was really secretly a
russian agent
like think about that for two seconds
that would get laughed out of a
hollywood plot
and yet that that took hold of the
liberal media for three years and was
promulgated by all the
you know the the reputable media outlets
it's just it's a total joke thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you